who you actually are is more important
than what you're doing that is at your
best and here's what failure looks like
in my opinion
if we become the biggest in the industry
if we make the most money in the
industry but we actually
become
people who lose kindness
and people who start
treating each other bad or people who
start backstabbing to climb a ladder at
think media then we lose
with the new year comes new goals new
ideas and new challenges and here at
think media we have coined this year
under the banner of at our best i'm
excited for today's episode because
we're going to be pulling back the
curtain and letting you in on an
experience that we just had with all of
our team here in las vegas we are going
to take you behind the scenes of our
leadership retreat and share with you
the heart behind our mission here at
think media for the at our best year my
name is heather torres and i'm the host
of the think media podcast the number
one podcast to help you grow your
influence on youtube and then turn that
influence into a high income and a high
impact online business and today we're
starting a two-part series where we're
going to be bringing you behind the
scenes of our leadership retreat this is
so much fun because over the years this
is something sean and myself have
envisioned for our team as our team has
grown we want to always be in a position
to gather together and really center
ourselves around a mission for the year
last year we brought in our team we
discussed so many wonderful things and
we put that episode here on the podcast
so i'll make sure to link that below but
this year we wanted to bring you into
our world again i think it's really
important to be able to learn from
leaders and to get a glimpse into what
does it look like to have a team and a
mission and all those things that go
with growing a business
today we're going to be focusing on one
of our core commitments we have four
core commitments that we're going
through this year and we're going to
start with the commitment to wellness at
our best is a book that we read by our
friend carrie newhof and we decided that
at our best is where we want to be this
year we want to be able to be at the top
of our game as we head into 2022 so
let's jump in as sean gives the first
part of the at our best series
[Music]
so our theme for 2022 is at
our
best
why what does that mean
so here's here's our definition of at
our best
what it's not is it's not saying
that we have to be the best
even though we want to pursue that
the cool thing about at our best
is
it's about being our personal best
because you know comparison is the thief
of joy
if we if we go you know
oh my gosh in a year's time
18 of us
hustled our faces off to get 50 million
views
we could compare ourselves to
just the mr b squid game video and that
was 30 percent of one video for him you
know so
so i mean in comparison to the thief of
joy it's it and and we want to learn
from and and of course it's good to have
as simon sinek says worthy rivals people
that inspire you and challenge you
but really our theme of at our best is
about being our personal best we are
competing
with the person in the mirror and we are
competing with the company we were
yesterday
we are competing
uh we are committing to showing up
at our best emotionally
physically and spiritually
we are striving to be our personal best
and be the best we can be as a team
working together in 2022.
and so this kind of
gives me an analogy for this did you
play sports in high school anybody who
who actually played sports in high
school here
pretty much all of us actually right all
of us
and so
um contrary to what isaiah thinks uh i i
played sports in high school i played
sports i was in football um i was you
know it was jv even as a senior but i
was uh i was i was in football and i was
in track
and actually over the last couple years
i picked up ronnie again
and i have now run multiple half
marathons
you can hold the applause that's fine
i saw i've run multiple half marathons
and and on the last one that i did
unofficially but my watch told me and it
was accurate i i beat i beat my uh when
the first half marathon i ran was a las
vegas
um
rock and roll marathon
and i think i ran it in about two hours
and 18 minutes i pulled like a muscle in
my leg
uh i felt awful after but i finished and
so
fast forward a couple years i ran in
snohomish down centennial trail
from like marysville to snohomish and i
broke the two hour half marathon mark i
hit like one hour and 54 minutes
felt amazing
but then
i turned on disney plus
and i discovered a documentary called
breaking two
now here's the premise of this
documentary after six months of
scientifically advanced training three
of the world's most elite distance
runners set out to break the two-hour
marathon barrier
not half marathon
this documentary is about the most elite
distance runners
breaking the an entire marathon in under
two hours and you know what's amazing
about the documentary they didn't do it
thank god because i actually seeing them
not do
not do it at least gave me a little bit
of regained confidence
i think the guy that got it did like
literally two hours and two minutes or
two hour and one minute can you imagine
discouraged f total failure
what a loser
and i mean it's super funny too because
literally they they picked a track that
was perfectly level and then a
temperature that was the perfect
temperature and they had blockers that
would block the wind so they'd have
people running around them so there'd be
certain like less wind resistance
and uh and so anyways here's the punch
line
you know if
i am i'm very proud of running a half
marathon at a decent pace but really not
that fast nowhere near a competitive
level no one's giving me any medals for
breaking two hours at a half marathon
but i personally have been getting
faster and i've been breaking
my personal record you know there's
league records right and there's
personal records this documentary was
all about and by the way he still broke
every record when he hit like two hours
and one minute
he he he changed the whole world he set
a global record well again when we think
about at our best it's not that we have
to be the best
we don't have to break the league record
but our goal is to break
our personal record right a personal
record is your personal breath it's it's
it's it's abbreviated as your pr anybody
go to the gym you know i was i was doing
my pr dog
it was put on my pr on the bench you
know what i mean i just
kyle's been putting up his pr and so
here's the question for you
what pr's do you want to hit this year
at your best
what pr's what personal records do you
want to hit this year our competition is
against the person in the mirror
second question
what would your personal best
look like this year
what would that look like now we're
going to break into breakout groups in a
second we're going to discuss that
but here's the crazy fact is that
again in the midst of falling radically
short and not even being on the same
playing field as these elite runners i
look this up
marathoners and half marathoners someone
who've completed at least even a half
marathon make up less than one percent
of the american population wow
less than one percent
so here's the truth just being in the
game and being committed to show up at
your best will put you ahead of those
who give up and settle you don't have to
be the best you have to be your best
and here's the thing i think with the
overflow of this this theme
is we desperately care
about our community and our customers
winning
but as player coaches
i believe that there's actually
something even spiritual that gets
released that when we strive and we rise
just to be our personal best and just to
break our pr's that there is like a
transference
that also just helps our community break
their pr's and if we can help more
people in our community just get in the
game
again i'm a 30 year old man
with compromised posture
that actually is really not that healthy
and that when you think about running
marathons it's pretty ugly and slow like
i always think i look like just an
absolute super athlete i'm listening to
some drum and bass sub focus music and
i'm like i bet i'm running around
there's probably smoke coming out of my
you know shoes right now there's
probably like lightning bolts am i the
flash did i just see arrow not as you
know his
his hat to me
and it really is pretty gnarly and
pretty but just being in the game that
you're in the one percent yeah if we can
get our community to say look i'm gonna
get in the game i'm just gonna do my
best i'm gonna get one percent better
with every upload one percent better in
the personal areas of my life then we're
gonna just see a release i think of
impact in our community so
at our best uh we're gonna talk about
four commitments of think media leaders
in 2022 four areas that we are committed
to being at our best personally and then
also as a team in this session we're
just going to cover one a little bit
later today we're going to cover another
one and we're actually going to keep
this series going digitally in a few
weeks we'll hit number three and then
probably in january we'll finish the
last one and so
at our best we want to be something we
keep building momentum on we keep
unpacking and you're a part of this
conversation and so we'll talk about
this in a second but we're gonna talk
about four areas of being at our best in
2022 here's the first one
commit we're gonna be committed
to wellness
a commitment
to wellness
how can you be at your best
if your energy your mental clarity your
inner peace
your stamina
and or your endurance
are compromised
like
it's not is it even possible to be at
your best
if you don't have inner peace is it is
it possible to be at your best
if you don't have stamina to face the
challenges
ahead the answer would be no
the answer would be no so interesting
when we think about making world-class
content work world-class videos whatever
it is writing the best emails showing up
powerfully on the phone you know
closing the biggest brand deals possible
or any of these types of things
how can we actually be at our best if we
actually don't have
wellness as a foundation
so what could your 2022 look like if you
were at your best in your health
and why is this important because
we want to run the race
and we want to finish strong
right
and so
as we talk about health that's not just
like physical health we're talking about
the holistic man what is at our best as
far as wellness and
you know i've watched now i've had the
privilege over the last couple decades
um and i've been observing
why
businesses and why people fail why
businesses and why people fail
um a couple just areas that i've
observed uh number one like fatigue and
burnout so when i think about what we
have at think media it's super special i
started thinking about man if we could
just keep this thing going
like amazing things are going to happen
so then what would take us out well
maybe fatigue and burnout
ariana huffington she's the founder of
the huffington post major news website
and news publication
she collapsed from exhaustion in 2007.
she was at home on the phone she's
checking her emails when she passed out
fell and woke up in a pool of blood with
a broken cheekbone and a cut over her
eye wow
and it was a wake-up call for her what
she actually realized was she wasn't
sleeping enough and she wrote a book
called a sleep revolution
because she wanted to build a business
she wanted to make an impact she wanted
to hustle and she was but fatigue and
burnout knocked her down
you know
there's this
tension in our culture
of especially
high growth high competition media
companies like ours
of of hustle culture and it's a weird
tension because on one hand we have to
hustle we have to work hard but on the
other hand
we have to be careful because we don't
want to fall into fatigue and burnout
because what good is it to like do 100
million views next year but then like
die
right
yeah
fatigue and burnout secondly uh
bankruptcy
bankruptcy and of course that could
happen from
not you know
not selling uh
products well or having enough revenue
or having enough but but i'm talking
about bankruptcy from poor financial
management caused by foolishness and
greed
you know when you're not at your best
and maybe you can relate to this
personally i know i can
that that
you may you might make poor
more poor financial decisions if you're
up late
shopping on the internet
trying to emotionally soothe something
that's happening in your life you know
and so foolishness and greed it's one
thing it's not really how much money you
make it's also how much money you
steward well
and and businesses have have collapsed
youtube creators have failed or gotten
sidelined because of this number three
emotional breakdowns
toxic levels of stress and anxiety
here's a couple headlines new york times
wrote this young creators are burning
out and breaking down here's the cnn
headline youtube burnout is rare real
creators are struggling to cope
you know our vision is to help ten
thousand purpose-driven people create a
full-time living doing what they love
while making a difference in the world
with youtube and online video
and
to achieve that success without losing
their soul
and so
we want to
pressure can be a good thing stress and
pressure create diamonds but we don't
want to push it to the point of
emotional breakdowns and friends i feel
like we are called
to help people in our industry
thrive as creators
create a lot of content work hard but
not break down and it's hap it's
happening on mass people don't know how
to handle the pressure they don't know
how to handle the stress
and here's the thing if we're player
coaches though if leadership doesn't
work at home we shouldn't export it
so this is why we're committed to being
at our best because if we're at our best
then we become the overflow to help
others be at their best and deal with
emotional
pressure substance abuse
pewdiepie
uh the largest independent youtuber
shared recently his addiction struggles
he said that he was drinking to escape
emotions and that that was a recipe for
a disaster that him alone with the
bottle was not a good combination
he said i used to drink whiskey every
single day and i realized i was getting
addicted when i tried to cut it down and
how difficult that was
substance abuse you know a few years
back
i i struggle with the same thing
um i was drinking two to three beers a
night
every night
for a long run like i might have had
like a lot i mean i might have hit
60 days like i mean it was just it just
became like a pattern right
and
i wasn't at my best
when that was the case i was wearing
that's that's not a healthy lifestyle
that's not a healthy thing to be doing
every night um but when pewdiepie was
making that video
i could relate so much because he was
talking about the emotional pressure it
was for emotional escape it was for not
being able to handle
the
the
whether it's expectations real or
imagined and so again if we're going to
be at our best
these kinds of details matter and in
this i'm just observing this is what
causes especially played out to the
extreme this is what causes businesses
to fail or what causes youtube creators
to affair uh fail affairs
multiple family vloggers and youtube
creators that i know personally
have had affairs
and what's interesting is that many of
them are family vloggers like their
actual thing was like family being there
and
you know this isn't coming from
any kind of a self-righteous stance this
isn't coming from like this is coming
from an awareness that life is messy
but
if we're going to be at our best i want
you to hear the foundation of 2022 that
this is the stuff that matters and that
we want to be thinking about this but we
also want to build a culture
that we can be in this for the long haul
right these are the kind of things that
could come in like we didn't see it
coming they come in and they can take us
out
and and then finally another reason was
just loss of vision and purpose
i've seen people get disillusioned
because they they
they trade in or at some point they lose
clarity and conviction and it gets
replaced for confusion and apathy
and usually that happens because we're
tired
you just you start getting worn down i'm
too tired i'm worn down emotionally i'm
numb in the pain with something at a
toxic level i'm you know and now man i
used to have so much clarity conviction
now now i've got confusion
and apathy
and again i know that life's messy and
i'm not taking a self-righteous stance
but what i'm advocating for is a
commitment to wellness that seeks to
dramatically reduce the toxic side
effects of an unhealthy soul
2022 friends at our best
is it going to be perfect of course not
are we going to struggle throughout this
year and years to come of course but i
think that this isn't talked about
enough
and this isn't like step number seven
that we should have in our to-do list
this is the
core
that everything else flows out of right
this is the inner
game that actually helps is going to
help us win the game
on the field
and so most often these things happen
because we're not being intentional
about setting up systems that prioritize
health and wellness and that's what we
want to do this year like we want to
just be thinking so i'm asking you
personally too this is of course think
media but this is a personal thing like
this is my responsibility it's your
responsibility to set up systems that
prioritize health and wellness and so
here's our verse of the year
and i want to read the verse of the year
but to understand the verse at the
highest level
we need to understand who was who was
penning the verse under the inspiration
of the holy spirit
so our verse of the year was penned by
king solomon now king solomon the
historic king of israel
was a pretty gnarly dude like
he was a king
he was a songwriter
he was in politics and leadership
he was involved in many construction
projects he he built wineries he built
palaces he he was in construction
projects of of homes in cities
and according also to the biblical
account solomon had 700 wives
he was known for
uh being the wisest man
to ever live besides jesus and and his
wisdom
historically was verified because even
the queen of sheba came from another
land to learn from him because his
wisdom actually was talked about in
neighboring regions before there was
social media in the metaverse to just
quickly spawn somewhere else like
he he was
and so he had this wisdom
and and sometimes people critique him
though and they go man how could he be
that why like 700 wives that doesn't
sound very smart and i'm like that's
probably where he got the wisdom that's
why he was like bro listen
you're trying to understand women dog
like i i i made a few wrong turns
so so if you think about because he
didn't live a drama-free life i think
the reason he had so much wisdom is
because he had so much experience right
and here's what he wrote in proverbs 4
23 verse of the year he said this
guard your heart
above all else
for it determines the course of your
life
wow
guard your heart above all else for it
determines the course
of your life
man that's at your best
i think the reason when i've been in my
knot at my best seasons
is because i wasn't guarding my heart
you know
it's it's one thing to get a hater
online it's actually not that big of a
deal
but it's a big deal if it gets into your
heart
right
and so
it's one thing to
you know maybe have some different we
can all get harmed in relationships and
different maybe relationships we've had
or
the one that got away in high school or
something like that right
that can touch your heart
solomon had 700 wives he had a lot of
stuff going on in his heart
you know he had he had a lot of real
estate deals a lot of pressure a lot of
stress
and and and what you actually see where
some people are confused because in the
book of ecclesiastes he's actually
all of even prosperity and growth and
and things he had built and things he
had done he actually lost his vision he
got disillusioned he got confused
and so the man who's writing guards your
heart stopped guarding his heart
and he just was no longer at his best
that's why this is our theme and that's
why our reverse okay so what does being
at our best look like here's just a
couple areas we're going to talk about
this and discuss this in just a second
this is not exhaustive list it's just a
list of like man what could it look like
for us to be at our best this next year
uh first area how about in our energy
an exhausted decision maker now we are
going to be sending you some cool stuff
in the mail uh to follow up as we build
this theme out
one of the inspiring uh
books we're going to be sending you is
called at your best by my friend carrie
new off and
after reading it it hit me so profoundly
for these very issues and it cut kind of
close and i was like man how is my heart
how am i doing and uh and then i was
running and i actually really felt like
i i heard it dropped like at our best
so we co it's carrie's title but
actually at our best is our title so we
stole it and carrie we're not going to
tell him until he sees this but
we stole his logo and we put on a hoodie
we're going to give you as well but like
we're ultimately but it's a little bit
changed so it's enough
that's right that's right
and legitimate legitimately i'm so
grateful i believe that this message
carries sharing is a needed message
maybe the most important message that
business owners and leaders need right
now because of all the anxiety and all
the pressure and all the emotional
breakdown and all the the mental health
challenges that that the world is facing
and uh and so a lot of these quotes in
this part i just kind of stole from him
but in energy here's what he said an
exhausted decision maker is a terrible
decision maker
it's exceedingly difficult to make good
decisions if you're tired
so if we're going to be at our best in
2022 then our energy matters
and one of the things we're going to be
exploring over the next few months
especially as we read that book and we
study is he's talking about how to be
at like how to make your most important
decisions or do your most important work
during your peak times
right because we have a lot of important
decisions to be honest friends the
decisions and the stakes are higher now
yeah we're making growth video live
decisions and the budget might be a
million dollars for the entire
conference when it's all said and done
the decision is a little higher now
like things are going really well they
also could go the other direction really
fast we got to guard our hearts an
exhausted decision maker is a terrible
decision maker
when i think about energy this can touch
on our health i heard a quote that said
if if it came from a plant eat it if it
was made in a plant don't
preach
energy
uh jack uh lalanne said exercise is king
nutritionist queen put them together and
you've got a kingdom
wow this is a personal decision if we're
gonna be at our peak energy for our
families if we're going to be at our
peak energy for this team if we're going
to be at our peak energy for our best
work and our legacy work
then energy matters home life our home
at our best
winning at work while losing it home
means you're losing period
now here's what i want you to hear again
number one is
i'm the chief mistake maker
i've made a lot of mistakes over the
years i've learned a lot and i
deeply care about you and your family
yeah
we deeply care i know you care about
each other's families
i want you to know that your home life
matters so deeply to me
and i want you to know that unless i
know what you're going through
that we can't make any decisions to help
so on the one hand
i i heather
whoever your team director is
they're going to be challenging you
giving you objectives giving you giving
you targets giving you things to need to
hit but here's the thing if you're in a
situation where you're like
man like literally like i need i need
some time i need a day
i need to take a half day so i can take
a date night
bring it up
because that's one of our values not
just stated here like
home life matters and here's what i know
if you're at your best think media is
going to do its best
period
and so
we want to win at home
so we can win
in life and in think relationships
who you're becoming is more important
than what you're doing
that value is contrary to
what's honestly being taught on youtube
what's being taught by even competitors
what's being taught by others
a lot of people say what i do
the gold play button i have the car i
drive
that
the the amount of people who follow me
is the most important thing that is not
what we're saying
who you actually are is more important
than what you're doing that is at your
best
and here's what failure looks like in my
opinion
if we become the biggest in the industry
if we make the most money in the
industry
if we build the biggest numerical team
in the industry
if we have the most core sales and the
most brand deals and the most ad revenue
and the most everything
but we actually
become
people who lose kindness
and people who start
treating each other bad
or people who start backstabbing to
climb a ladder at think media or people
who
just kind of become
terrible people
in the process of building the biggest
kingdom then we lose
like actually who we are and and i think
that's what will continue to make think
media special
is
is
is us
living it out first and just being
people of core value and character and
letting that spread to our community
and
you were your most kind
when you have the most margin
isn't that true
well thanks for nothing sean because
like that's actually your like and i get
it so this is this is just we're putting
this as these are goals the point of
goals is to say there's something to
reach for
and this is something that i want to
reach for because we all know it like
you're the best person in the world but
when you're tired and it's the end of
the day and there's too much pressure
and we've added too much then you then
we start to fight right then we start to
be short with each other because why is
our fuse short because we've been
burning the fuse all day long and for
weeks on end and so we want to create
margin again so we can be our most kind
sleep like ariana huffington don't buy
into the 20 hours a day entrepreneur
myth you need eight hours of sleep if
you want to have a focused mind that's
james altucher
just sleep
there's all kinds of things about our
best but just sleep
alone has been proven
a lack of sleep impairs attention in
your working memory
it affects other functions such as
long-term memory and decision-making
and partial sleep deprivation is found
to influence attention
especially vigilance
lack of sleep means we're not at our
best
and when we sleep check this out it
increases fertility it wards off heart
disease it increases sex drive it
prevents diabetes it boosts mental
well-being it can slim you and it boosts
immunity
sleep's pretty dang important
at our best
at our best
character when you're exhausted bad
things seem good and good things seem
bad which is the perfect setup for moral
failure
i learned this this is fun write this
down i learned this
[Laughter]
write this down
write this down halt
h-a-l-t halt
halt is it halt is literally something
to remember
to like stop take a pause don't do it if
you're hungry
halt
if you're angry
halt
if you're lonely
halt
and if you're tired
pretty that is fine
[Laughter]
like but like for real you know what i
mean there's probably there's nothing
you're on a work trip you're alone
and you're lonely and you're mad because
you got in fight with us your
significant other and you're exhausted
exhausted and you're hungry you probably
make your worst decisions that night
right you know what i mean and so
so
when you're exhausted good things seem
uh good and or bad things seem good and
good things seem bad which is the
perfect perfect setup for moral failure
peak productivity
working on the most important things
first
and working on the most important things
when you're at your best energy
that's what we want to really dive into
this year and especially as we unpack
the book that's kind of kerry's whole
system of at your best is is reaching
that peak productivity by saying okay
man if we need to make really important
decisions let's make sure to put the
right meetings in the right place
there's also times when your energy is
lower we'll work on different tasks at
different times my friends man i believe
when we tap into at our best this year
it's going to reverberate into the
momentum we have the impact we make and
so at our best is our theme for 2022
and there's been some things we've been
trying to do right you've seen this of
course our pto sick days baby bonuses
federal holidays
team retreats
our goals that you're compensated
properly related to the cost of living
of your area and your job and we're
working on leveling up that even more
and so
this is our theme in terms of practical
things we want to do as a company more
planning more foresight
christmas bonuses which are coming up on
the next pay period
again you being resourced that you would
have financial margin all of the above
because we really want to be committed
to this this theme and as we land the
plane
you know steve jobs said this he said
i'm convinced that about half of what
separates the successful entrepreneurs
and businesses from the non-successful
ones
is perseverance
this is what i this is what at our best
matters
because again
it's one thing to have a good year but
it's a whole other thing if we're still
healthy five years from now
able to have stamina eight years from
now
and what culture is telling us and what
our industry is telling us is it's
fighting against that this is a
resistance this is something to push
back again this is something that
transparently
i struggle with i am the over committer
i am the
led by opportunity visionary that is
saying we need to do this because it's
not just about the next three months or
six months and there's times to sprint
but it's about being at our best over
the next decade business is a game of
attrition unfortunately
a lot of our competitors are going to
lose because they're going to burn out
they are going to just hit a wall
they're going to not be able to sustain
it over the long haul because of not
prioritizing this we do not celebrate
that in fact we want as many people in
the game as possible and we want them to
hopefully catch this message because we
care so deeply about not just our our
health but everybody's health we want
everyone to win
and they can't if they're not at our
best how do we persevere over the long
haul wellness
wellness and we want to build a company
and a culture for the long haul
um a couple values as we land the plane
if i have the applause of the crowd
but i have lost the love and respect of
my children i've failed
i want to be
at my best at home
if i have a billion dollars in the bank
but i've bankrupted my physical health
to get it i've failed
our mission is to succeed without losing
our soul therefore well-being and health
must be a part of our definition of
success
and we don't need you uh we need and and
i just want to say again
you're needed on this team yeah
if you're on zoom right now
you're watching this on the replay
you're in this room
you're needed
and we need you at your best
i need you at your best honestly your
family in the world
also needs you at your best
well i hope part one of the at our best
series was encouraging to you to dive
into the wellness that you want to
commit to for this year and i'm so
excited because our team has already
been taking action into this area of
where we want to grow and the
commitments we're making to our wellness
you know burnout is real and we want to
avoid that on every single level we want
to be here for the next 20 30 40 years
producing this podcast making great
videos creating courses and doing live
events like we're doing and we can't do
that if we're running on fumes so i'm
excited because at our best year is
going to be so phenomenal and part of
that year includes our grow with video
live conference this is our annual
conference that we host here at think
media and can you believe it it is back
live in las vegas may of 2022 you can
get your tickets right now for general
admission and vip at
growwithvideolive.com we have already
locked in some amazing speakers like
gary vaynerchuk sean cannell and some
other great speakers that i can't quite
tell you about but maybe on the website
when you head over to
growethvideolive.com
it's gonna be like a conference you've
never been to before because we're not
just focused only on youtube we're
focused on you dominating with video
through your business that means
everything from social media to what
types of content you should be putting
out and so much more we want to help you
center into the fastest growing small
business type happening right now and
that is content creation i'm hearing
stories of content creators right now
who are selling their youtube channels
for multiple seven figures i can tell
you that when you grab your general
admission or vip ticket at
growthvideolive.com
you'll be making the commitment that
this is your year i cannot wait to
announce more speakers that are coming
out soon but you want to lock in that
ticket now because
vip is selling out fast general
admission we have so many amazing things
for you but vip if you want to be in the
room and you want to have those special
experiences lock in that ticket today
and send it to a friend come together be
a part of this community with the
powerful people that you're going to be
networking with at groweth video live i
cannot wait to shake your hand
hear your story and if you're a hugger
like me to give you the biggest bear hug
in person as we head into this year of
content creation so head over to growth
videolive.com right now and grab your
ticket well if you've gotten value out
of today's episode i want to encourage
you to subscribe whether you're
listening to this on apple or spotify or
you're watching or listening over on
youtube click the button that says
subscribe so that you get notified when
new episodes come out every single
tuesday and over on our youtube channel
we are posting more and more content
there that's in video form like our
collaborations with vid iq and the
channel reviews that we're doing or the
youtube made simple show or the coffee
with kennel show we have so much content
for you over on our youtube channel so
make sure you go there and subscribe as
well and for being a subscriber and
someone who left a comment i want to
shout out multiple careers thank you for
leaving your comment over on our youtube
channel you said what a great episode i
can totally relate to this i've also
noticed that some of my best performing
videos were the older ones that felt
less produced one of my next steps i'm
going to spend more time going through
my analytics multiple careers left this
comment over on our collaboration with
vanessa lau about is your youtube
channel broken so if you haven't checked
out that video you could do that over on
the podcast well thank you so much for
being a listener thank you for being in
our think community we are so encouraged
by this year and i can't wait for the
next episode where we're gonna dive into
part two of the commitments that we are
making here at think media i hope that
this message encourages you and we'll
catch you in the next episode